So let's understand how the RC memory model works with a concrete
example. So let's say the programmer's intent is that one
thread of his program is going to modify a structure A. And there
is another thread that is going to wait
for the modification, and then it is going to
use the structure A. So this is the
programmer's intent. Right? So P2 is going to wait for
the modification, use it, and this guy is
the guy that is modifying that particular structure
A. And of course these are running different
on processors, and therefore we don't know who
may be getting to their code first. So let's say that P2 executes the code that
corresponds to this semantic. That is, it wants
to wait for the modification. So in order to
do that, it has a flag, and this flag has a semantic that is, 0 indicating the
modification is not done, and 1 when the modification
is actually done. And to make sure that we
don't do busy waiting, we use a mutual exclusion
lock. We lock a synchronization variable, let's call it
L. And if the flag is 0, then it
is going to execute the equivalent of a pthread_cond_wait.
You know, pthread_cond_wait has the semantic that
you're waiting on a condition variable and you're
also releasing the lock that is associated with
this condition variable. So you execute this pthread
wait call, and the semantic you know is that at this point, thread P2 is
blocked here, the lock is released, and he's
basically waiting for a signal on this condition
variable c. Who's going to do that, well, of course
P1 is the guy that is modifying the structure,
so its the responsibility of P1 to signal him.
So let's see what happens. So P1 is executing the
code for modifying the data structure A, and once
it is done with all the modification, then it
is going to inform P2. So in order to
inform P2, what it does is acquires this lock L,
and it sets the flag to 1. And the flag is the one that I inspected over here
to know that, oh, the modification is not yet
done here, and I'm waiting on this condition variable.
So, P1 sets the flag to 1 and signals
on the condition variable, c. And, you know that
signaling on the condition variable is going to wake up
P2. And, of course, it cannot start executing here until
P1 has released the lock, and once the lock has been released, that lock will be
acquired implicitly by the operating system on behalf
of P2, because that is a semantic of this
condition wait here. So when I wake up,
I'll go back, and as a defensive mechanism,
I'll recheck the flag to ensure that the
flag is now not 0, indicating that the modification
has been done, so I'm now ready to get
out of this critical section. I unlock L, come
out of the critical section. Now I can use
this modified data structure. So that's the semantic that
I wanted, and I got that with this code
fragment that I'm showing you here. So the important
thing is, if you have an RC memory model,
then all the modifications that I'm making here that
are modifying shared data structures can go on in
parallel. With all this waiting that may be going
on here, I don't have to block the processor
to do every one of these modifications. The only
point at which I have to make sure that
these modifications have been made globally visible is when
I hit the unlock point in my code. So just before I unlock L, I have to make
sure that all the read write accesses to shared variables that I've made here in
my program have all been taken care of
in terms of the coherence actions being communicated
to all my peers. Only then, I have to unlock it. So, in other words,
this code fragment is giving you pictorially the
opportunity for exploiting computation in parallel with communication.
If the model was an SC memory model, then
for every read-write accesses that are being done in
modifying this data structure A, there would have been
coherence actions that would have gone on, and those coherence
actions, each of them has to complete before you
can do the next one, and so on. But
with the RC memory model, what it is allowing
you to do is, you can do the data structure
modification you want, and the coherence actions inherent in
those modifications may be going on in the background,
but you can continue with your computation until you
hit this unlock point. At this point, the memory
model will ensure that all the coherence actions are
complete before releasing the lock, because once the lock
is released, this guy's going to get it, and immediately
he'll start using the data structure that has been modified
by me. So it is important that all the coherence actions
be complete prior to unlocking. So that's the intent of the RC
memory model. And that's how you can exploit computation going on in
parallel with communication if the memory model is an RC memory model.